foreign
[Music]
you hate talking about Bitcoin and
energy I do why
I just feel like you have two sides they
have their opinions they're very
entrenched opinions neither side are
going to change and because of that it
becomes just very heated and emotional
very very quickly I don't I mean that
sounds like good content it it just it's
like watching a presidential debate like
maybe there's going to be some zingers
or like some viral moments but it
doesn't feel like we're actually
discussing it so you think nobody
changes their mind I don't think so okay
we're gonna try to we're not going to
try to necessarily change anyone's mind
today okay but we want to give everyone
all the information that they need to
sort of understand Bitcoin and energy
Brown
[Music]
Bitcoin uses a lot of energy experts say
crypto uses more power each year than
Argentina
the energy it takes to process one
single Bitcoin transaction could power
the typical American home for more than
50 days
Bitcoin is so energy intensive because
it relies on minors high-powered
computers that process transactions
these attempt to solve really complex
problems and then get rewarded in the
form of Bitcoin when they succeed
and more computers are trying to do this
the amount of computing power needed to
process transactions hit a record
earlier this year miners are trying to
lower their carbon footprint by using
Renewables but the share of Renewables
used to power bitcoin's Network actually
fell between 2020 and 2021. all of this
is happening at a time when the world is
seeing one of its worst energy crises in
decades and it raises quite a few big
questions
is there an eco-friendly way to power
crypto
and perhaps even more importantly
should energy even be going to crypto
while the world struggles to keep the
lights on
Alex it's good to see you thanks for
joining us so it's not really in dispute
that crypto uses a lot of energy that
Bitcoin uses a lot of energy I I think
that the dispute the argument is that
it's not worth it to use a finite
resource
for something like cryptocurrency but
what would you say to somebody who says
no I believe in the promise of crypto
and it is worth it for for us to
actually spend a finite resource like
energy mining it and on maintaining it I
I I would indeed agree that if any
amount of energy is being spent you
always have to look at what do you
ultimately get back from that and the
thing is when we look at the Bitcoin
Network we know that is it is a digital
currency a payment system and we also
know that it is a payment system that is
currently handling about 100 million
transactions a year so that means that
it's actually not handling more than a
handful of transactions per second and
that's it which is completely negligible
if you look at it from a regular world
of Finance perspective because the
traditional financial institutions are
responsible for handling more than 700
billion digital payments every year and
that amount is still growing so I mean
that's an amazing stat but to be totally
honest part of the reason I don't like
having conversations about energy is
because and Bitcoin and crypto's energy
uses is because on both sides
it sort of devolves into a toxic
conversation is what I found and I've
found that there's a lot of bad faith
arguments on both sides and I know that
you're deeply rooted in the numbers in
the actual facts but what's your best
sense about why people get so emotional
over these numbers
well it's not that hard to see why that
is the case here we see that a lot of
people have invested their money in
Bitcoin and we see that this type of
data reflects extremely poorly on
bitcoin and well actually to the extent
where we see that China took action to
completely ban cryptocurrency mining
from their country in the spring of 2021
the European Union almost banned Bitcoin
trading in the EU a few months ago and
actually the White House just released a
report that also recommended consider a
potentially eliminating cryptocurrency
mining so of course with a lot of people
having invested in this they definitely
won't like this whole discussion
definitely and and certainly not if
that's going to resolve in outright bans
it's hard to have a conversation about
energy and crypto's use of energy
without talking about about the ethereum
merge of course the transition from that
blockchain from proof of work to proof
of stake which of course is much less
energy intensive Could That Be The Green
Solution for the industry broadly Beyond
just ethereum
well I think so I mean if if you run on
proof of stake or well and we must say
it's not the only alternative to the
process that is responsible for so much
energy consumption in Bitcoin but it is
definitely the most popular alternative
in any case let me just say if you make
use of proof of stake you can probably
get away with using
something like 10 000 times less power
than you would need if you were to run
on proof of work so just changing that
part of the software can lead to
incredible Energy savings and we see
that there are many cryptocurrencies
already available in the market that are
running on proof of stake and have been
running on proof of stake for years so
if yeah if if you do that and if that
becomes the standard for the industry
then a big part or almost the entirety
of the energy consumption we're talking
about could be solved Alex DeVries
thank you so much for joining us you're
very welcome if if I can say one thing
as I I have we talked about pool for
steak but we didn't really bother to
explain uh anything have we just
mentioned that it could save a lot of
energy is that something you might want
to spend a few extra words on like why
is it even possible to save so much
energy if you do that but it's a bit of
a lengthy explanation it may be too
technical but yeah can it be can it be
in 30 seconds do you think like in a way
that's digestible for normal people
in 30 seconds well
um digestible maybe uh 30 seconds
challenging
challenging eh well when you have it
scripted by a Bloomberg journalist and
thrown in a teleprompter it's actually
pretty easy so in under 30 seconds
here's the difference in proof of work
super powerful computers owned by miners
compete to be the first to unlock a
cryptographic puzzle after multiple
attempts using up lots of energy one
Miner solves the puzzle if they're first
they get a token and a transaction is
recorded proof of stake dispenses with
the problem solver removing excessive
energy use instead transactions are
approved by participants who put up
coins as guarantees of their work and if
that work is validated you get a reward
if it isn't you don't see wasn't so hard
Zach Bradford CEO and president of
cleanspark with us now in studio what's
interesting about clean spark is it
sounds a little bit like an oxymoron a
sustainable Bitcoin mining operation
what does that actually mean in practice
how do you fulfill that sustainable
check mark our focus on sustainability
really comes down to you know both
sustainable energy but also sustainable
business practices and how we interact
with the community so for us you know
energy is a big deal around Bitcoin we
approach it with the acknowledgment that
energy is a feature and not a flaw and
you know we focus on sustainably
interacting with the grid but also we
use about 90 percent carbon free Power
with a goal of ultimately getting to a
hundred percent at some point in the
future
but it takes time we think that being
part of the transition is what what
matters you know getting from point A to
point B and in a sustainable process
what is carbon free hour so carbon free
Power can come in many forms it can be
solar it can be wind we actually use a
lot of nuclear energy which puts off no
carbon into the atmosphere so that those
are kind of the Cornerstone of the
energy sources with that we use
do you also tell us about the role of
carbon offsets because I know that there
are a lot of miners who do use carbon
offsets how much of that is part of your
business model very little so again we
we focus on the source so we're only
using about 10 percent of the power as
any sort of carbon off put right now it
can be a strategy right but not all
renewable energy credits or carbon
offsets are created equal right so
anything that we do we try and you know
go through a mechanism that results in
new solar generation being added to the
grid so that's that's the only one that
we participate in right now do you buy
power that is carbon free or are you
actually generating it yourself we are
buying power so so you don't have your
own solar arrays or anything not right
now we don't we are adding a Solar Ray
to one of our facilities in the near
future but it'll still just be part of
what it is so we we connected directly
to the Grid in the areas we operate in
oh okay a question that I have
a lot of pressure on the entire industry
yeah right now and then you layer on the
need or the push to become sustainable
it feels like it's fallen way down the
priority list because there's a lot of
miners who are just trying to stay in
business right now and in this path to a
sustainable a green Bitcoin mining
future
how much has that timeline been pushed
out
you know I think it's actually been
shortened in some ways because it's
actually getting more important you know
some of the conversations are actually
leading to quicker change so you know
depending on how you pull the industry
but it's estimated that about 60 percent
of the power used by the industry is
already renewable or carbon free now
that still leaves a big gap to close but
if you were to compare it to any other
industry we're actually doing a lot
better in most cases what would you say
to someone who says okay electricity is
still a finite resource even if we're
getting it from renewable sources and
they just don't think it's a good use of
energy to be mining crypto they would
rather that energy be used for keeping
the lights on or running air
conditioning in hot places I would say
you know look at the regions that miners
are operating in
miners focus on finding cheap power it's
part of our strategy right and and you
know we operate a lot in Georgia where
there's actually abundant power so would
I say it would be a good use to come
into California which has a very you
know the grid is unstable and under a
lot of stress and open up uh Bitcoin
mine probably not but ultimately if you
do it in Georgia or a few other places
like that where there is abundant energy
we're actually focusing on using the
underutilized resources that do exist
and then adding to the generation so
again you have to think of it as a
transition about what we can add
I have a series of simple questions yes
if we can go there let's talk about the
ethereum merge
um the switch from proof of work to
proof of stake we've all seen the
headlines that it cuts ethereum's power
usage down by 99 or something
why can't Bitcoin just go to proof of
stake yeah it seems like a pretty easy
solution well I would point to again
proof of work is and the energy it uses
is a feature and not a flaw
again proof of work what is bitcoin you
know there is no CEO of Bitcoin it's
fully decentralized and really proof of
work is the really the only good way to
truly secure a blockchain without an
overseer and that has value because
Bitcoin is used worldwide as a currency
without you know somebody changing the
the mechanism what creates that value is
ultimately there's only going to be 21
million Bitcoin ever so somebody can't
just decide tomorrow hey there's going
to be 40 million it's kind of like you
know we're all experiencing what the
fed's doing right now to kind of pull
back from inflationary you know money
printing that won't happen in Bitcoin
without reminds me of another simple
question I have 21 million Bitcoin will
ever only be mined we're at 19 million
now I believe yes what happens to the
miners when we get to 21 million
they will essentially live off of very
small fees so think of Visa Mastercard
amick these are all companies that are
very large and function very well on
actually very small incremental fees
that's what will happen but you know
that doesn't happen until 2140. so every
four years there's a halfing so
basically the reward right now gets cut
in half every four years so even though
you say oh there's only two million left
how do we get to where it's 120 years
before the reward Runs Out
by that time the expectation is that the
Bitcoin essentially truly functions the
worldwide currency and the small
fractional transaction fees can be
support all minors so even started
planning for the
for them we have not started planning
for 21.40.
2140 or 2140. so 120 years from now
we're still talking about Bitcoin yeah
exactly you know I think we're all going
to be in the metaverse yeah it'll be
fine which is and everybody will be
using Bitcoin there so if we think about
crypto mining compared to mining of
Natural Resources a lot of the
competitive Advantage has to do with
location so you know De Beers has great
access to Diamonds and Rio Tinto perhaps
in the US has great access to Copper
whether or not they can get it is a
different story
um what's the competitive Advantage for
a Bitcoin miner for for your company
yeah and it is partially location right
so for example we have four facilities
in Georgia
and the reason we chose these are the
ones you guys recently bought yeah yeah
we've we've we've had you know we've
been operating in Georgia since 2020 we
recently did buy two more
um and these areas where we're at is
we're kind of on grid Edge areas areas
where there's actually excess
infrastructure excess energy that's not
being used and because it used to be a
factory or something like that so yes it
allows us to get good rates on power but
we're also bringing back to communities
um you know workforces factories that
used to be there are closed so we have a
Workforce that's ready to go we have
energy that's ready to go and lower
rates but couldn't any Miner do that yes
you know absolutely and to the point
that you recently made a few
Acquisitions when you broaden out and
look at the broader industry in this
moment where uh we've gone through a big
downturn would you expect more
consolidation between some of these
minors absolutely you know for us we we
saw it as a big opportunity but you had
to have a healthy balance sheet you had
to not be over leveraged you had to be
ready for this you know downturn it's
something that we've been preparing for
for a long time and so the miners and
we're not the only ones the miners that
have prepared there's definitely going
to be some consolidation in the space
can you explain because Kitty and I've
talked about this a lot and I don't know
if anyone really has been able to answer
this for us when we think about mining
if we if we take it back to like pulling
you know natural resources out of the
ground yeah that's clear to understand
how somebody gets gold or or oil or
copper out of the ground
Bitcoin miners don't just find new
Bitcoin
they also help keep the Bitcoin Network
running yes can you explain the
difference between like discovering new
Bitcoin versus maintenance on the
network yeah so really what we're doing
all the time is we're processing data so
you know we have tens of thousands of
computers processing data and what that
data ultimately is is it's you know
locked by a cryptographic key and that's
what our machines are trying to guess
and so they're putting in all this
effort to do that but ultimately when
you get a block so what is the block the
block is The Ledger of all the
transactions that got recorded So if you
know you sent Bitcoin to your brother or
whatever it may be right
that ledger has to then be compared to
all the ledgers before it and so all of
this work is going in to make sure that
it's secure and that block doesn't get
placed without verifying everything
behind it and if there's an error then
the block doesn't get placed you also
don't get the reward
do you actually need to be on the grid
like couldn't you find a spot in the
Mojave Desert that during the day it's
hot and it's sunny and it provides solar
power and then at night it's windy so
you can get wind power so you could you
know in a perfect world be running 24 7.
couldn't you just be self-sustained
absolutely you could and but I would
also argue that then you're providing
your own benefit with that energy right
I think there's true and this is how
we've always set up the company there's
true ancillary benefits to the grid that
provide value we actually operated out
of California for the first six years of
our business not as a cryptocurrency
mining company but as a renewable energy
company that's how we got into the space
and what we found is the interaction
with the grid was incredibly important
so we had software that would do that
and at scale though you start to run
into these interesting issues to where
you know Renewables going onto the Grid
at the wrong times of the day is
actually causing a problem for
California there's too much power
hitting in the grid well the sun is
shining and everybody's at work and
they're not using all their power at
their home and they go home at night the
sun goes down they turn their TV on they
turn their AC on come on some Bitcoins
yeah whatever they may be doing and now
there's not enough energy at that moment
so it was about balancing the time the
energy is available not available and so
you know really interacting with a grid
we see is important because if we do a
behind the grid project or behind the
meter project where we're
self-generating wind and solar yes it
means that we're only using Renewables
and we're not impacting the grid but it
means we're not helping the grid so it's
definitely one way to do it but it's
it's not the way that we've approached
it because we want to drive change at
the entire grid level we really think
that our sustainable strategy should
provide a benefit to everyone around us
so convince me who you know
for the sake of argument just a total
crypto skeptic that we shouldn't be
spending any energy on cryptocurrency
that it should all go toward
you know actually essential things that
we need power for like this light board
behind me that probably doesn't use much
energy because it's LED but you get the
idea yeah I would I would point to the
fact that that energy that we're using
is generally already available but it's
no one's using it and so you think of
you know I'm going to point to you know
uh
one of the communities we operate in
okay they have a goal to transition off
of coal
and they're in the process of doing so
where's this this is in Georgia okay
um it's actually in College Park it is
the same city that serves the Jackson
Hartsfield Airport we operate there and
we are working with them to help them
transition away from any Reliance right
and this has been a multi-year strategy
for them it's not that there isn't
enough power and I think that's a
mindset that that we can change is power
is abundant it's around us it's about
how it's harnessed and if we're there to
pay for it all the time we can help
support grid infrastructure which in
this country we need to invest a lot in
great infrastructure but why do you have
to be mining Bitcoin to do that I guess
I guess what I'm still not hearing is
like the argument about as the argument
and this is the argument that totally
bothers you I think of like why Bitcoin
should exist
well let me ask what else what is it
going to be used for and how if let's
I'm going to put myself as the utility
now right when you know in Georgia it's
been a hot summer when the power prices
are peaking that also means demand is
peaking
we shut off we you know all that power
goes back into the community we can
actually help reduce power rates in
communities because being a large buyer
if it's not being purchased when you
know it's off peak then that means that
they have to take those dollars and they
have to put them back into the community
somewhere right and so we're we're
actually able to do all of those things
so we're really providing a grid service
in addition to everything else so the
question is why Bitcoin I would say
point to another
um asset or another business that's
willing to do that come on the grid Off
the Grid and really interact in a way
that balances both you know the grid and
the power itself but also balances the
monetary system behind utilities and I
you can't find one you know if you're a
regular data center right now
um which which is a whole other
conversation but you have to be there
all the time you can't just shut down
because there goes somebody's website
right or there goes somebody's backup
system
um you know something that we're not
talking about just pointing to Data
Centers is you know why why data centers
why can why is it okay to you know host
hundreds of megawatts of selfies of
power all the time 24 7 and set up in a
system that cannot interact with we got
a tweet yeah yeah I know the people need
my content
true yeah thank you
Tim I think I made it pretty clear that
I did not want to talk about energy you
really did not want to do that episode I
actually got a lot out of it good that's
the idea so much so that I believe we're
going to do a whole nother episode on it
all right let's do it okay
[Music]